I'm just wearing my dead boyfriend's shirt and texting his old number.
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of these.
I have a phone.
You have a personal phone.
This is a work phone.
I miss you so much.
There's an aching inside of me.
Do you have a question for me?
Yes, Ms. Dion.
Do you really believe in all these things you sing?
You obviously know nothing about it.
What?
Love.
It's been two years since you passed...
...and I still can't believe it.
Who is sending me these texts?
Every morning I open my eyes hoping I'll still see you.
I must have the dead boyfriend's number.
That's super sad.
I think they're nice.
Remember that yellow dress?
I'm wearing it to the opera tonight.
I gotta go see her.
These are from a literal stranger.
I just need to put a face to these texts.
Do I know you?
I'm not sure.
Oh my God.
You just got yourself a date the normal way.
Oh, I was looking forward to this.
I just felt like I knew you or something.
Do you think you could fall in love with someone just through their words?
I think you're very cute.
The more I get to know her, the better I like her.
Things like this don't just happen.
Love has a plan for each and everyone of us.